und schon wieder kündigt sich eine
verblüffende erkenntnis an ein
forschungsteam hat im zentrum unserer
galaxis etwas verblüffendes gefunden
einen ganzen haufen schwarzer löcher
noch ist es nicht ganz sicher doch der
verdacht erhärtet sich mehr mehr was
dafür und was dagegen spricht und welche
konsequenzen diese erkenntnis hat jetzt
den klicks um science-fiction herzlich
willkommen
und übrigens wieder mal einen
themenvorschlag der über whatsapp
reinkamen vielen dank an die hammer
community dort wie er da rein kommt
erfahrt ihr am ende des videos diese
entdeckung ist mal wieder ehrlich
unglaublich und verändert wahrscheinlich
mal wieder die sicht auf unser universum
ist sieht so aus als ob um das schwarze
loch im zentrum unserer galaxie der
milchstraße hunderte kleinere schwarze
löcher kreisen schon länger gab es
diesen verdacht um das zentrum der
milchstraße kreisen ja unzählige objekte
aber bisher war es eben nur ein verdacht
dass es dort auch schwarze löcher gebe
jetzt konnte ein team um den
astrophysiker charles jay haley erstmals
konkrete hinweise dafür finden dass wohl
hunderte schwarze löcher um das große
supermassereiche schwarze loch
sagittarius a stern in zentrum der
milchstraße kreisen sind nicht viel
schwerer als die sonne
aber es gibt eine menge davon es sind
stellare schwarze löcher also solche die
aus der masse eines zusammengestürzten
sterns entstehen und dann kaum weitere
materials ihn aufgespürt hat das
forschungsteam die schwarzen löcher in
den daten des weltraumteleskops chandra
dort fanden sie zunächst hunderte punkte
von denen energiereiche strahlung
ausgeht das sind röntgen binärsystem
kombinationen aus schwarzen löchern und
einem stern oder einem neutronenstern
und einem normalen stand das wird
vermutet alle fünf bis zehn jahre sparen
sie eine große menge röntgenstrahlung
aus wenn kein schwarzes loch dabei ist
allerdings gab es sechs runden quellen
ohne größere ausbrüche das
forschungsteam vermutet dass es sich
eben um schwarze löcher handelt sollte
diese erkenntnis bestätigt werden dann
dürften sich hunderte solche systeme mit
kleinen schwarzen löchern rund um santa
rosa stern befinden das team vermutet
sogar 300 bis 500 solcher schwarzen
löcher im abstand von nur 3,3
lichtjahren rundum sagittarius
aussterben bei mir kommt ja sofort
wieder die theorie der schwarzen löcher
statt der dunkle materie hoch wenn es
immer wieder mehr schwarzer löcher
entdeckt werden man kann es sogar sein
dass irgendwann gar kein platz mehr für
dunkle materie ist und ist da schon
dadurch bestätigt wird das wäre
sensationell aber noch gibt es nicht
annähernd
schwarze löcher die das erklären würden
aber sie sind zumindest genauso schwer
zu finden wie die dunkle materie am ende
habe ich euch ein video noch zu dieser
these verlinkt naja es bleibt spannend
wenn er als erstes neues zum thema
schwarze löcher und zu allen anderen
themen erfahren wollt wie eben auch die
dunkle materie
dann endet meine telefonnummer hierbei
whatsapp dann erfahrt ihr von mir vor
allen andern vom neuesten video
garantiert ihr könnt dort direkt über
mich in der redaktion von kriegs- und
mitmachen oder mit themen vorschlagen
oder an abstimmungen teilnehmen und
mitbestimmen was hier bei pixum passiert
der direkte draht zu mir einfach hier
draufklicken und natürlich nicht das
aber mit der genau blogger vergessen wie
geht es weiter
dafür auch draufklicken eben mit dem
video dunkle materie rätsel gelöst
spielen schwarze löcher eine rolle
ansonsten bis dann bleibt